واحد من الاف المشاهد التي لا تحضرها
عدسات
الصحافه مدنيون تقطعت بهم سبل الحركه في
خضم الحرب اصابهم رصاص لا يفرق بين مدني
وغيره استشهدت العائله وبقي الطفلتان على
قيد الالم ليان وهند وتلك اخر الكلمات
التي وثقها اتصال ليان بالهلال
الاحمر مرحبا عمو
الو الو مرحبا
عمو الو مرحبا ايو بخ علنا الدبابه جنبي
انتم متخبين اه في السياره احنا جنب
الدبابه انتم جووا
السياره
الو
الو كل ما نعرفه ان الرصاص انهى ذلك
الاتصال الهاتفي مع الطفله ولا شك ان
كثيرا من كلماتها وصراخها انقطع عنا
بانقطاعه اما سياره الاسعاف التي هرعت
لانقاذها فقد اصبحت دون اثر مثلها في جوار
تلك
الدبابات في جوار
المجهول وذاك صوت استغاثه سمعناه يشابه
اصواتا وصرخات خائفه كثيره لم
نسمعها يقول
المسعفون لم تكن هذه القصه هي القصه
الاولى عشرنا الكثير من القصص التي حدثت
مع طواقمنا اثناء تعاملهم في الميدان
والكثير منهم من استشهدوا من الاطفال
نتيجه يعني هذه المعاناه التي يعانيها
شعبنا الفلسطيني هنا في قطاع غزه قرب
المستشفى المعمداني ينتظر من بقي للطفله
الاصغر من اقارب بصيصا من الامل وتتك كرر
الاستغاثه على امل ان تجد اذنا هنا او
هناك اخويا وزوجته وثلاث بنات
وولد كانت في طفله صغيره اللي هي هند هذه
هند وين وين ليان قال ليان ماتت وكانت
بتبكي بتقول انا متصابه الحقوني بسرعه طيب
يا سيدي هلقيت بنبعت لك الاسعاف عنده وصلك
الاسعاف والمن الساعه خسه مساء طلع
الاسعاف اللي فقد الاتصال فيه ولحد هذه
اللحظه واحن بنستنى في مستشفى المعمداني
على امل انه تعود هذا الطفله البريئه اللي
مالهاش اي ذنب لذلك احنا من هنا بدنا
بناشد جميع المؤسسات الدوليه وجميع حقوق
الانسان جميع احرار العالم بالتدخل لانقاذ
هذه الطفله البريئه اللي مالهاش اي
ذنب عم ليان ورغد وهند واحد من اقاربه
واحباء كثيرين علت اصواتهم تناشد وقف حرب
اودت بارواح الاف المدنيين والاطفال منهم
تحديدا لكل منهم قصه
وناشدهم
واقارب واحباء ووجع مستمر مع استمرار اله
القتل الدائره في
غزه